what we're referring to as existential
agency existential agency we define it
as people's belief in their own ability
to guide the meaning in their life to
have a meaningful life
clay rutledge welcome to the show
thanks for having me it's great to be
here for the people who aren't familiar
with you and your work how do you
describe what you study
well i'm what's called an existential
psychologist and that probably sounds
like what what's he talking about um so
obviously i'm a psychologist i'm not a
clinical psychologist i don't see i
don't see clients or patients i'm i'm a
psychological scientist so i do i mainly
do research and so the existential part
is what i'm really interested in is the
uniquely human capacity
to ask big questions why am i here
what purpose do i serve does you know
does my life have any meaning that
transcends my mortality
what does it mean to be free you know
the idea of free will agency
um curiosity creativity
you know there's just all these things
that we can do because we're intelligent
and you know we're clever we're
imaginative
and so everything kind of wrapped around
that idea the big questions is what an
existential psychologist is interested
in and then of course more you know that
sounds very very philosophical so more
concretely and practically how does that
connect to human well-being like how do
my concerns about meaning in life
influence my goals
my ability to be mentally and physically
healthy my relationships the types of
beliefs i have you know so everything in
life that you know that's really
important to navigating
you know the world and society and and
families and cultures
how does that connect to these deeper
questions of meaning and agency that's
pretty much in you know in a nutshell
what i'm into
why does any other psychologist not
study that because that sounds
absolutely
fascinating yeah well i mean i think a
lot of it is it does
it sounds intimidating in some ways
because it's so it sounds so abstract
and so one of the challenges we have
as you know scientists is trying to
you know trying to connect these broad
ideas to empirically testable hypotheses
and so i think a lot of a lot of
psychologists they're just you know
they're just understandably interested
in very specific things like
depression or schizophrenia or
you know those types of issues um and
you know those are obviously those are
important
very very important issues but
i'm into these kind of broader questions
which i think have implications for
those for those issues
um so but but i do think a lot of people
are like well you know that's too
fuzzy
um and it's it's hard it's hard to get
at but it is i think it's a growing area
of
a growing area of interest i think there
are more and more people
that are interested in psychology and i
think a lot of that is driven by an
increased awareness that
clearly humans want their lives to be
meaningful
um we're not machines and we're not just
we're not just driven by
money or
practical security concerns you know
like being having shelter um having you
know having food
um
we want something we want something
more than that i mean
the simplest you know example
is like you could think of what if you
were like you know filthy rich you had
everything you wanted like you had a
mansion you had a yacht you had you know
um
the access to the best medicine
um that wouldn't you know my guess is
that would be pretty cool
but that wouldn't necessarily um
be totally fulfilling i mean
you you might be bored right you might
be like well what's the point of all
this
and so i think even if you control for
all these kind of basic security needs
that people have to feed themselves to
feel safe
we long for something
for something more to have an impact
on the world and so i think more and
more people are realizing
realizing that's that's actually a
really important driver of human
behavior
what do you mean by meaning how do you
define it
yeah so that's a really good question
because there are different ways to
define it i mean i think that the
simplest way to define it is people's
subjective sense that they they matter
that their lives have value that the you
know people that they're significant
that they make a difference so i think
that that element of significance and
mattering um but when you get into you
know deeper into into the research you
can actually think about meaning at
multiple
levels and so you can think about
meaning at the level i just talked about
which is pretty high level like i want
to matter in the world i want to make a
difference i want to be significant
but you can actually think about it and
study it at a much
lower cognitive level and what i mean by
that is
part of meaning is just perceptual
patterns which is you know the visual
world making sense and so if you go into
like a
a modern art museum
and you see like this crazy modern art
you know this absurd art right and it
doesn't the whole point of a lot of it
is to be like this is not what you
normally expect these patterns violate
your expectations and there's something
that's kind of cool about it but also is
a little bit
jarring right it's a little bit like
well those things aren't supposed to go
together
um and so you know and so that that kind
of effect that has on us is is in part
because our brain is about pattern
making sense of the world about patterns
and we need patterns to you know if you
didn't get up every day with a certain
level of
consistency that you know what's going
to happen right that you know
roughly what the weather is going to be
like how other people are going to
behave then your life would be chaotic
and you'd be stressed out and very very
anxious
so we're constantly trying to make sense
of our reality and so if you think about
that low level of meaning of just the
world making sense
you can even think of meaning as not
even
uniquely human right you can say well my
dog has expectations
for for the world making sense right my
dog thinks that in fact my dog
magically knows that it's 6 15 in the
morning and it's time to get me up
regardless of what i want
and so
we're not the only organisms that need
to make sense of our environment but
what happens is the more intelligent the
organism is
the more high level that becomes so we
don't as humans because we can
self-reflect we can think about our own
existence and what that means we can ask
these big questions i was talking about
we don't want to just make sense of our
physical environment
the world around us we want to make
sense of our own lives and so it's that
ability to turn inward to introspect
about our existence that makes meaning
this higher level issue of i don't just
want the world to make sense i want my
life to make sense
is that what you mean when you talk
about cohesive meta narratives
yeah yeah so i mean if if you so you
could think about the pattern perception
thing right you can think about just the
simpleness of like i want the physical
environment to make sense but we live in
a symbolic world as humans right because
we're smart and so it's not just that i
want to be able to walk around my city
and there be some order
to it physically to the physical
environment i want there to be some
order to the rules the the norms the you
know the customs the traditions that we
have and so there's this there is this
cultural narrative or what we often
refer to as cultural world views
of that we think that order our order
our lives and help us say well this is
what we think of as good behavior this
is what we think of things we should
aspire to do things we should avoid
doing and so these these cultural
narratives are very important and they
they really
add the parameters you know they add the
structure the scaffolding for our
personal meaning system because how do i
know what's meaningful or what it means
to make a meaningful contribution to
society well a lot of that is derived
from the cultural world view that i um
that i've adopted and the cultural world
that i live in
what's the biological driver behind our
search for meaning because it like if
lacking meaning can be a huge course of
suffering to people it doesn't seem very
adaptive that an animal requires all
this extra work to just be able to
flourish he said like the solution to
your dog's problem is to make sure that
he's opened out for his walk at 6 15.
the solution to giving a human meaning
is this huge question that's been
wrestled with for millennia
yeah
so there's com there's a lot of debate
a lot of debate around around that
question so there what there is one
theory and i i've done work in this
theory i don't i don't do as much now as
i used to but there's this theory called
terror management theory and the
argument according to terror management
theory is that
humans are uniquely aware of of our
mortality right we're the one species
that fully understands what it means to
live and die
and so as a result of our intelligence i
can look forward into the future
and that can be cool because i can
imagine all sorts of great things that
might happen but that also renders me
aware of the fact that no matter what i
do no matter how often i go to the gym
no matter how many you know healthy
shakes i drink and go to the doctor and
do everything i'm supposed to do i'm
still gonna die right and so according
to terror management theory is that
unique awareness
of um that just kind of comes with being
intelligent right it's not
you know that it doesn't it's not for
like a specific reason it just comes
with being intelligent that we're aware
of our mortality
causes a unique anxiety for humans like
every organism faces a certain level of
anxiety related to the threat of death
but for other organisms like a rabbit
like it has a fight or flight response
there's a predator and it's like it's
got a very brief moment of terror
and then the threat goes away and it can
go back to business but humans we can
think about that we can ruminate about
that and we understand that that threat
is coming someday for us no matter what
and so according to terror management
theory this this unique intelligence
um comes with a great deal of anxiety in
other words like with great intelligence
comes through the potential for great
anxiety and so
according to that particular theory what
meaning really the function meaning
serves is to help regulate that anxiety
so the response to
understanding that no matter what i do
to take care of myself i can't avoid
death forever
is to feel like well but part of me
doesn't die
i'm not just a physical organism i'm
part of something bigger than myself and
obviously you can think about that
quite literally in terms of religious
traditions that offer some hope for life
after death but even if you reject that
you can think of immortality as being
symbolic right you can think that well
as an individual organism yeah i'm gonna
die but i'm not just an individual
organism i'm part of a family
i'm part of a nation
i'm part of a culture
and to the extent that i can make
contributions to that
yeah i'm not real excited about dying
but i'm not just totally snuffed out
like part of me continues
continues on so you know that that's one
that's one theoretical perspective that
meaning
is a response
to the awareness of inevitable mortality
there's other theories that
that
take that idea and say okay well that's
mortality is one
threat but there are other existential
threats it's not just like i'm worried
about dying but i'm you know there's
there's threats like worried about being
socially ostracized like what if
what if i don't have anyone that cares
about me loneliness is a you know is a
major concern so fear of rejection
the fear of uncertainty like not only am
i going to die but i have no idea what
that means and what's going to happen is
there any is that it
is it going to be painful
what would about the people i leave
behind how are they gonna you know are
they gonna be devastated so um so other
people have made the argument well
there's a whole bunch of anxieties that
are related to
to mortality and other potential
existential threats and so what meaning
is is a response to that but in a lot of
these theories
a way to you know to kind of maybe
connect them all is to say they're all
about some type of threat regulation
right that
that we face threats things that make us
anxious things that make us scared um
things that maybe demotivate us because
another another response isn't just to
be terrified but to feel like well
what's the point like why should i work
hard and do stuff to contribute to
society when i'm gonna die and then
everyone's gonna forget about me anyway
and so
the the idea is to be an organism as
intelligent as ours requires some kind
of motivation
beyond this beyond the self or to
grapple with the transients of the self
there are other perspectives too um you
know you could imagine
it's a similar to that regulatory thing
but you could imagine it without even
thinking about the threat component you
could just imagine well you just need
some kind of inspiration in life because
life's difficult
and
and so
if you get up every day and just kind of
like focused on like the immediate well
i just get food in my belly then our
civilization doesn't really flourish you
need people to want to create
works of art you know i mean some of the
you know some of the biggest
contributions to
um you know to culture and to
architecture into religion you know i've
been projects that have transcended one
individual's lifetime and so somebody
might be working on something and be
like this might not even be completed
when
you know before i die but i've made it i
i'm part of that so i think there's
something about our ability
to step outside of our physical selves
that um
that has been you know that's very very
adaptive right that has allowed us to
say there are projects bigger than me um
and because if you just focus on like my
you know if you're just like i just have
to focus on making sure i stay alive and
maybe my kids because you know like you
know my you know my gen you know genetic
continuity right you know i'm wired to
protect my offstring but there's just so
many so many challenges and and society
that require self-sacrifice right they
require you to look beyond yourself and
to have a vision
well into the future say well you know i
want to i want to care about making an
impact so from that perspective i think
you can imagine meaning as
not just about protecting
you from your anxieties but inspiring
people to to
for for big for big goals and bringing
people together for big goals um so
that's another theory there are others
but you know that kind of
i think those kind of that kind of sums
it up it's pretty compelling man like
life's hard
the the desire to overcome suffering
requires something more than just
like if it wasn't for the fact that
there is meaning or some sort of ability
to transcend
all that you'd be doing is say well i'll
get past this suffering today so that i
can get on to tomorrow's suffering
tomorrow that's not very compelling
argument but right that does not sound
like a very fun life
so yeah i understand it's um
it's interesting that it's kind of like
a defense mechanism
that it's there
in a lot of these theories as a way to
assist us
with the inevitable
vicissitudes of life as opposed to
enhancing life and making us better and
i think that
probably that would be explained by the
fact that we're built to be effective
not happy it doesn't really matter
whether we're that happy all that
matters is do we survive and reproduce
and if you can be
potentially sold some sort of
transcendent lie by your own programming
that
this
this thing that you're contributing this
podcast that you're recording really
does matter in the wider scheme of
things make sure that you keep going
until you have children this
football team that you play for really
you know the religion that you attest to
all that sort of stuff um so yeah i i
i'm quite sort of seduced by the idea
that it's a byproduct of being very
clever that you have humans that are
super intelligent well they are super
intelligent compared with everyone else
that's around
and
a byproduct of that is this ability to
consider our own death
and when you have that you think oh
maybe the intelligence is worthy of that
maybe being intelligent is such an
advantage
that the fact that we have to deal with
death is is just a small price that we
need to pay but we still need to be able
to compete with it and the desire for
meaning and
and transcendence is one of those does
how does purpose
relate to meaning is purpose part of
this what does it do
yeah yeah so certainly and eve among the
researchers who study this they they
consider purpose kind of a sub component
of meaning because like i said before
you can think of meaning at this very
very abstract level of
things ranging from just a coherent
environment to my life having direction
and that that self part that my life
having direction is often what people
are referred to as purpose like it's so
the purpose is very goal
is a very goal-focused
way of thinking about
about meaning like i have a purpose and
in addition to that you know new area
that i've been you know but i've been
working on with some call colleagues to
develop and this is very very new very
very new research is what we're
referring to as existential agency
and it relates the purpose but i i think
it's different in an important way so
purpose you could say is
i've been given a purpose right like
this is you know you can imagine purpose
outside of your own decision making
right you could say i'm you know my
purpose in this world is to do x
some people would say no i create my own
purpose
but that's not inherent in the concept
of purpose because you can have
goal-driven behavior that you feel like
you were you were assigned like you
could say my purpose well like you said
a minute ago my purpose is to reproduce
right um
existential agency is
you know we define it as people's belief
in their own ability to
to guide the meaning in their life to
have a meaningful life so you could say
my life is meaningful
because i have this religious belief
that you know that says all you know all
life is meaningful and i've been given
this purpose
but within that you need some kind of
drought like you need to feel like you
have the ability
to take action and to do things not just
be passively pushed around
and to say well i guess this is my
meaning i guess it's not my meaning so
there seems to be this this more
self-regulatory dimension of meaning and
that's what we call existential
agency but it is connected to purpose um
and people who you know like i said this
is very very early work
but it seems like people who have a
strong sense of existential agency
even if you
control for how you know how meaningful
they see their lives it's the people who
have a really strong sense of agency
that are the most motivated they're the
most driven they're the most resilient
and they're the most entrepreneurial you
know so they're the most willing to take
risks and a lot of it has to do with the
fact that they see themselves as
responsible
for their own meaning right they feel
like when life feels meaningless they
can change it
they can do something about it as
opposed to people that you know maybe
are just more like well
i guess it just wasn't meant to be and
i'm not you know
i can't do anything about this or my
meeting is really contingent on these
other external forces
and and so i think that that's and i
think that's a part of the reason i
wanted to to really start to figure that
angle out
was because i feel like we increasingly
are living in a society at least here in
the
in in the us and i think this is the
case more broadly in the western world
where people are acting like you're not
in control of anything
right there's all this you know there's
all these concerns about like systemic
um
oppression and things like that and you
know this isn't to take away from real
structural challenges that people
face
but the point being is
if we're only talking about those things
that are
we think of as outside of people's
controls we're neglecting the fact that
humans have all this cognitive
horsepower up here
right regardless of what situation you
were born into in life and again clearly
there are privileges and advantages and
differences between people um
but regardless of that there's something
going on within the within humans that
gives us a great deal of cognitive
freedom if we choose to act on it
right um so i could get up tomorrow and
say
you know i've been kind of lazy every
day and but this is going to be the day
that i you know i get my act together
and people do this all the time
you know people
set goals all the people change their
life for all the failing things we hear
about like barriers to things people all
the time absolutely
take action based on goals that they set
and priorities that they make um
in order to take control over their
lives so i'm really interested in that a
genetic component of meaning
well think about why anyone ever gets
seduced or finds it really sort of
emotionally fulfilling to see those
transformation photos of some guy ethan
suplee one of my buddies the guy that
was in remember the titans and
donnie darko a bunch a bunch of films
and um
he lost like
350 pounds
like he lost
two humans off of himself
and
the reason that people love that story
is that you see someone that you thought
was going down a particular path that
had a
meta narrative that they were attached
to and they were on the rails but
through force of will and effort they've
managed to
change the cart onto a different set of
railway tracks and they've done that
through their own agency so i think that
people intuitively are aware of this
it's
i think you're correct to say that the
victimhood mentality that we're seeing
at the moment um
completely outsources existential agency
and
if
man can make a heaven of hell and a hell
of heaven
then your ability to interpret how the
world is talking to you and how you are
experiencing it is more than 50 of the
battle
you know you have people that are in
like terrible terrible situations who
are able to be
relatively fulfilled and people that
seemingly have everything lottery
winners that kill themselves so you know
your material situation is an influence
but it's not a determinant you know you
would say maybe it predisposes but it
doesn't predetermine so
yeah i think that framing things in that
way
and
allowing people to understand and
encouraging them toward look take
advantage take control of the
of the direction that your life's going
in i think that's a smart area of
research
yeah yeah thanks no and you you summed
it up perfectly i mean and it doesn't
even have to be because people tend to
think of your example is a good one a
dramatic one but even little even little
things so you know people do
you know like you'll see research on
like even just increasing the amount you
walk
every day so you know even people who
are like i'm going to make some gigantic
transfer
transformation but it's a choice just to
say you know what i'm gonna take the
stairs
instead of the
the elevator or i guess you would say
the lift right
like i'm gonna i lived in the uk for two
years
i think i remember the word still um
but there's lots of little things that
people do
every day and even if
even if there are you know because again
you know and you made this point it's
true like even even if you start out
with certain vulnerabilities so let's
say let you to use an example think
about like a genetic predisposition
towards alcoholism
right
some people
just for whatever reason
can't handle drinking
a lot of us can a lot of us have no
problems just saying you know like i
drink you know sometimes a lot sometimes
hardly at all and i can turn it on and
off that well it's no big deal
other people they just they can't crack
the bottle they really can't
but
what so so one so the victimhood
narrative as you described it which you
see a lot is
well alcohol abuse isn't really a choice
because it's a genetic disposition
and it's a disease and it's you know
but
and so what's funny is the more we learn
scientifically about that the more
people intuitively seem to think that
well you have no control over it
but another way to look at it from an
agency point of view is thanks to our
scientific understanding of genetic
vulnerabilities you've just armed
somebody with information so now they
can say you know what i know i'm the
type of person
that can't be at the pub
that can't have alcohol in the house
and those are choices to set up your
life based on information that you now
have and so yeah and it seems so obvious
but just that simple difference of
looking at it from oh this is a genetic
predisposition i'm hopeless
to know learning learning about genetics
actually gives me
information um about my personality
about my vulnerabilities things you know
things that tempt me things that bring
out the worst in me
things that things that motivate me what
is it that inspires me to be at my best
like so the more you can learn about
these things scientifically those aren't
like determinants that that doesn't mean
like
you know your life is just being you're
just being pushed around by these by
these external causes they're
information that can help you make
choices to you know to live a better a
better life so i actually think that as
as we learn more and more about
you know you know you know the science
of the brain
that doesn't mean we're less in control
that's giving us more information about
how to how to regulate our own behavior
but my feeling is that's kind of a
minority position in the modern day
scholar you know western scholarship
instead people just seem to think well
here's another excuse here's another
reason why you're not it's not your
fault
um i'm like well no here's more
information that that arms you with with
the ability
um to make better choices
the presumption that knowing more about
the way that you operate
forces you into a tunnel i think has got
everything backward does this uh kenp
rinpoche quote where he says
the choice in life is between the
discomfort of becoming aware of your
mental afflictions or the discomfort of
being ruled by them
like that's a great quote
there it is like look
this is going to happen whether or not
you want to know about it like your
genetics or your genetics if you decide
to read robert pluhmann's blueprint or
not
it's still they're still there for you
they're still controlling your behavior
so do you want to become aware of them
or do you not
and then do you want do you want to take
control of them or not because you can
either be at the mercy of them or you
can try and account for them and that's
really
that's really all that we've
all that we've got what about um what
are some of the predictors what are the
biggest predictors of having meaning in
life
yeah so the the the biggest one okay
well let me say this way if you ask
people
what gives their life meaning which is
some research we've done and we've we've
have people who are we've asked people
who are religious who aren't religious
of different ages of different you know
belong to different groups
um
overwhelmingly everyone says
relationships like family and friends so
meaning appears to be very very social
um so that that's a first that's that's
one piece of information that's
important now what i think the mistake
that sometimes people make is they turn
that into oh so meaning is just about
being liked
and being included
um well no i don't think that's
that's what it is what it means is
meaning what it really is
if you look deeper meaning is about
mattering to other people and you know
getting back to the idea of you know
you're talking about how we evolved and
you know ways of thinking about it from
a more perhaps evolutionary point of
view
if humans are
a tribal
species and if you look back you know
certainly in the modern world we have
lots of advantages and you know advances
now that kind of allow we still need
people but you can i can like pay
somebody to mow my lawn or
you know we can
through trade we can make all sorts of
arrangements even if no one likes me um
but
if you look back you know and in our
ancient past
um you and when life is more dangerous
and
and we lived in small groups then it was
really important for you to have a role
right for you for you to be like well
you know here's what you're good at
here's how you know here's how you
matter and so it is social
because you have to you know you don't
the tree or a rock or the ocean doesn't
care about it it doesn't care about you
other people care and the reason other
people care is um in addition to like
where we're kind of naturally social is
we need each other
and so it really it's that feeling of
like my family and friends need me and
so i i often use this example and it's
silly but i think it illustrates it
pretty cleanly which is imagine a
situation in which you're part of a team
this can be a work team or you know any
kind of group you're part of and
everyone to everyone in your team is
really really nice to you
very inclusive
never says anything bad
you're great um everyone thinks chris is
wonderful all right um
but when it comes time to actually for
the for the team to do something you're
like okay well what's my role what am i
going to do imagine if your teammates
were like oh well we don't need you to
do anything you're just we just love you
chris and you're great um
you just chill out you're fine we don't
need you to do anything now that
situation doesn't sound very meaningful
it sounds like people are being nice to
you but you're sitting here thinking
well why am i like a loser like i can't
that you know i don't have anything to
contribute
now and in real life you know the other
situation oftentimes our relationships
are a little bit more messy right
they're not everyone's nice to you all
the time because we have all sorts of
motives and vulnerabilities and
insecurities and you know conflicts and
things like that but what a mat what
matters um for you to you know to feel
socially valued is that your team
actually needs you to do something right
that chris is good at x or you know
chris can deliver on this
and so it's not
another way of thinking about it it's
not just being liked it's serving an
important function
and it's easy for us to see or it's
often easier for us to see that with or
we care about it more whether with our
with our close family and friends
because those are the people we matter
to those are the people that count on us
and so this connects to something that
i'm actually
i think might be a growing concern you
know
in our
is this you have people you have this
you know supposed loneliness epidemic
that people talk about but the funny
thing about loneliness is you can and
this has been documented in you know
some of the early research on loneliness
people can actually feel lonely
even when they're surrounded by others
so you could get up every day you could
have a roommate you could have
co-workers you could have schoolmates
around you all the time but you still
feel lonely and how's that possible well
it's because you don't really feel like
you matter
you feel like you're in fact people who
have been ostracized they often if you
just ask them to describe the experience
of ostracism what they'll say is it
feels like they're invisible
and in a way it's been described by you
know by researchers as
ostracism is like social death it's an
existential threat like we were talking
about before
um you're still physically alive but
you're invisible you don't matter and so
the biggest predictor of meaning is
really mattering it's like it's like
it's a social thing you have to you
matter to people
but it's more than just
people being
nice to you and i think that's important
um
because imagine a lot of our imagine
some of the things we care about like in
schools and education where the
anti-bullying and you know all these you
know these ain't these campaigns for for
kids to be nice to each other not to be
cruel which you know that's great
obviously we don't want people being
cruel to each other but people need even
children they need to feel like not just
that people are being nice to them but
that they have a significant role to
play
in the group that they that their
contributions
matter so we could have a very very
polite and kind society
that's
superficially social
but a deeper
you know i would rather you yell at me
chris i'd rather you and i have a
conflict but it's because
we're we're both doing something
important and
we realize that sometimes important
things come out of
challenge adversity as opposed to well
we're never going to say anything mean
to each other we're always going to just
be really you know kind because we don't
want one's feelings to be hurt and you
know i'm exaggerating a little bit but
you know to the extent that we go in
that direction let's not you know let's
just make sure everyone feels safe and
comforting and and
loved
if it's if it's at the cost of people
actually having something to do to make
a difference in society um then that's a
you know
that's a i think that's a worrying trend
yeah this sort of what do you say like
dictatorial meaning it's like
bureaucratically bestowed top down
like that's not that's not a thing i
mean we saw this last year
with um
the
black lives matter black square
so if you didn't post the black square
oh yeah
there was something implied around what
that meant
and
people were much
happier
to see somebody be coerced into posting
something they didn't believe
they would have they would have
been more comfortable with a comforting
lie than an uncomfortable truth or even
just nothing let alone truth like truth
sounds like people were would have been
going against it's like i just didn't
post it but that wouldn't have been
enough and i i think that
it's interesting it's interesting to
think
about how meaning relates to the social
side of things does that mean that
does that mean that
meaning in isolation
kind of doesn't exist
if you're an isolated individual
yeah no that's a good i i think that's a
good way of thinking about it because
why do we care
about anything
um and if you were the so if you were
the
if you were the last person
uh
on earth right if you were the last
person on the planet then
it yeah it probably would unless you
felt like you had some way of rebooting
the species right it would you know you
probably would feel very meaningless
right like what's what's the point in
fact this is one of the um
i think this is actually
an issue that people who are concerned
about things like climate change should
pay a little bit closer attention to
because if you want to motivate young
people
to make the world a better place
it's not a good strategy to take this
apocalyptic world view of well we only
have
i don't know it depends on what week it
is how many years we have
left but you've probably heard all this
before like this this total apocalyptic
you know you know terror of well what's
the point like we're all or just it's
too late
and you see that kind of wrapped up with
the antenatalism right there's no point
at you know we should just quit
reproducing humans were a mistake we're
destroying the earth and it's not going
to be inhabitable in 50 years or 20
years or 100 years
well that's a very
demoralizing position to take that's not
going to inspire people
to make any sacrifices in fact if
anything it it might have the opposite
effect which is it might make people
more hedonistic
and more greedy and selfish because if
you're like well there's no you know
there's no point there's no future you
might as well go out with a party
right so you might as well just you know
be like well i'm just going to look
after myself and enjoy my life
but if you think there's
some kind of challenge or threat
coming in the future but one that's you
know that we can manage
and through science and engineering and
you know you know other types of you
know goal directed behavior then you're
more likely to get people to you know
to say okay well you know there's things
i would like to do but i'm not going to
do this because i'm serving the you know
i'm serving this the
this higher good
um but i see a lot of and there
definitely are i mean if you look at
like technology if you look at
innovation and entrepreneurship and and
certainly in the business world i think
there are a lot of people a lot of
companies and a lot you know
a lot of entrepreneurs that are trying
to come up with new types of technology
cleaner energy
ways of just
um
kind of calibrating our life to to
manage
the fact that you know there
there might be changes um
in our in the climate right and not
being like insane about it but just
saying hey this is a challenge and
humans we're clever we've overcome
challenges before we can do this there
are people doing that but then you see
this and you know they're just doing it
i think in you know and and largely in
the business world
but then you see like these activists
that are um not all of them i mean i'm
i'm not trying to
you know over generalize but that do
have this more
very like nihilistic apocalyptic view
and i mean i guess i just don't know
what the purpose of that is i think i
think the reason that people are doing
that is they they presume that because
if they overshoot
the severity
or if they give it the most grand
seeming
level of significance that they can that
maybe this is going to motivate people
into doing it but it sounds like what
you're saying is that's based on a
misjudged view of how human motivation
works
yeah yeah no you're right i i think so
big time i mean you just people have to
have a you people have to feel like
there's there's a reason to try
and and it so you could i know that some
people have argued that
this apocalyptic environmentalism is
like a meaning system like they're doing
it because it's like gives their life
life meaning but this gets to i think
the question of well not all
meaning worldview existential related
worldviews are
are the same
right um
apocalyptic ones that act like well
you're you're the last one you know
you're you're the righteous
you know chosen few which some of this
does have like a fundamentalist for
fervor you know again not all of it but
some of it definitely does well that
might make somebody feel somehow like
they're part of some group um
and that's meaningful
but it's not really a solution focused
future focused source of meaning and so
i would say that all
all meaning projects aren't created
equally and it's healthier not just for
individuals
because obviously like people are
i mean there are people i mean some
people i think are being over the top
but i do think there are people that are
legitimately like
completely terrified
and they're very very anxious and
they're they're mentally not healthy um
and that's not that's not really a way
for them to live and it's not really
helping in fact it's it's hurting for
you know for you know because it's d
it's demotivating the people who would
care and it's making other people feel
like this is you know these people are
just being ridiculous they have nothing
to offer and maybe they do have
something to offer because like you said
maybe they're overshooting
maybe they just throttled back a little
bit and said okay well here are some
things that we can do
can we come together as reasonable
people and you know and try to moderate
our behavior in some way or come up with
some new um
innovations
and technological innovations um
that can you know that can help us take
this take this problem on
what is some of the most robust ways
that people can actually add meaning to
their life then
so i think what you know the
one of the best ways you can do it or
one of the things again this gets back
to the social element of meaning it
seems like the more people
um
feel like they're giving
they're looking beyond
the self and helping others
the more they feel meaning so pro-social
behavior so helping you know
taking care of family
helping out you know in your community
um working on you know not every job
here here's another here's another thing
that i think is interesting is that
we often think about like well your work
you know we talk about a lot and you
know i'm in a department of management
in a business college and we talk a lot
about meaningful work
and i think that one misunderstanding
about meaningful work is is people think
well i have to feel like every day when
i go to work that what i'm that tasks
i'm doing
feel
meaningful but a lot of times at the
lower level what we're doing doesn't
feel that meaningful it's just boring
stuff
um
but so what people what helps people
actually
have meaning is that they can attach it
to something higher
what we call higher order goals so you
know this is you know to use a an
example from like physical training
if you're training to run a marathon
like
and if you're if you had the goal of
like this higher order goal of training
to run a marathon that feels like a
pretty pretty big
accomplishment right
um but that goal is actually made up of
a bunch of sub goals right and those sub
goals are things like train you know
going on you know increasing the
distance i run you know fluctuating on
you know
coming up with a training schedule
increasing my caloric intake eating the
right types of foods and things like
that so
those but that's not like that doesn't
sound super
meaningful um
like if i'm say like writing a book that
sounds pretty cool right
but that's made up of things as low as
typing words on a keyboard
that doesn't sound particularly
meaningful right that sounds kind of
boring and so i think one of the things
that people need to be able to do to
really achieve meaning is to be able to
attach even their mundane kind of
ordinary
day-to-day grind to bigger longer term
projects and goals
especially ones that are oriented
towards serving others serving your
community helping you know helping build
something beyond yourself and this is
why it's good for organizations this is
helpful because it's good for
organizations to think about that their
employees don't need to feel like
entertained all day long and need to
feel like everything's you know this big
epic thing but it helps if you feel like
what you're doing even if it's small
even if it's just you know cleaning it
cleaning an office that that's actually
you're a meaningful member of the
organization you're part of a team
that's working towards a mission a
certain cause or you know some purpose
and you play a significant role in that
and sometimes those things are going to
feel you know inspiring and interesting
and sometimes it's just going to be
like mundane chores that we have to do
um so i think that's that's important
and again a lot of those things they're
about are about relationships they're
about like
feeding my family
so again a job might not be exciting it
might be boring but where people might
get meaning from that job is is not the
particular duty but the sense of like
i'm taking care of people like i'm doing
something i'm putting food on the table
and i think that's um that that's really
important
it seems to me like a lot of these
questions had already been answered by
religion and tradition
am i wrong there like is it
it seems to me have a community that you
feel like you're contributing to have a
local group of people that know who you
are and that you have a role within it
um build a family
have a job you know
a lot of this a lot of this was probably
already fixed right no you're absolutely
right i mean there's tons of things that
we do and
you know and this is picking on myself a
little bit because i'm obviously a
modern empirical psychologist there's
tons of things that we do that are just
rediscovering
like old wisdom you know i was listening
to a podcast a while back and you know
they were
they were you know they were talking
about this idea of
well what if you took a portion a
percentage of your salary
and don't you know it's like they were
rediscovering the concept of tithing
right it's like
it's like and then they settled on well
what if it was like 10
like this whole idea of like altruistic
giving and it's like again not to you
know not to take away from
from those rediscoveries but it's like
yeah those are all you're right those
are old ideas i mean a long time ago you
know people came up with you know
figured these things out a lot of this
is rediscovering old old wisdom i think
but you know getting back to an issue
that that you raised about culture
i mean i think in any given time
a society a culture has to make things
like speak in their modern
way so now you know we care a lot about
science right we want things to be
empirically tested we
you know that that seems to be
the guiding cultural narrative of the of
the modern west so
in other words we might be we might be
like revisiting old ideas but we're
scrutinizing them using new
techniques and tools
of science and then we're putting our
own our own spin
you know kind of our own spin on them
and so i do think you know rediscovering
these things is just part of
you know part of culture looking back
and seeing like well what worked and
what didn't and then you know you
cultures forget
right they rediscover things because
they forget because you know it's easy
to to go in one direction and think oh
this is really cool this is the way we
should go
and then for things to get stress tested
a little bit and to me like you know
what like we should get back to back to
this way of thinking that actually
connects to another area of research i
do in
existential psychology that's focused on
nostalgia
actually that i don't know if that's
something you want to talk about yeah
yeah what's it about also it makes me
think
about a shane parish quote where he says
the whys of every generation discover
the same truths
oh yeah yeah yeah no that's a good
that's a good quote
um
yeah so i you know i do research on
nostalgia and typically when people
think about nostalgia they just think of
like silly marketing sports memorabilia
sports memorabilia or you know vintage
clothing old music things like that
um well it turns out what a big aspect
of nostalgia that that's existentially
helpful
is nostalgia really is about the
memories that we cherish the things that
we find meaningful and often they are
connected to these these things that
seem kind of silly
like
like sports memorabilia and old movies
and music and things like that but those
connections are usually because
that was that was those objects or
experiences
are connected to memories
you know to to specific times in our
life that something seemed really
important and so what nostalgia seems to
be or a big part of nostalgia seems to
be
people's ability to reach into the past
to find the lessons
that help them
move forward
so for instance you might be really busy
right now um you got lots of stuff going
on with you know with your career with
you know other things and
and
it's easy to forget
like how important relationships are
time goes by really fast it's it's easy
you know you often um hear these
anecdotes of older people saying wow
like looking back i wish i would have
spent more time with my kids or you know
doing focusing on this i was so worried
about
it
being successful at work or accumulating
money or whatever and they look back on
these things what nostalgia does is it
kind of helps
it helps direct you because you're like
oh yeah these are really this was really
important memories that i have
um and
i'd like to have stuff like that
again and so it's it's kind of like a
priority check yeah so you use the past
as a
forecasting tool to project the future
right into what and the things that you
want to
spend your limited you know time and
energy
on and so in a lot of ways i actually
think nostalgia is a very future
as a future oriented experience because
it's reminding you of what you care
about even like the silliest example of
going on holiday where you're like you
know oh that was a really cool trip and
then you kind of forget about it and
then maybe 10 years later you're like
oh i haven't done that in a long time
and
that was awesome like i really need to
make that something like that happen
again
and so it does have this kind of
um guiding effect and the reason i
brought that up
in response to the rediscovering
old truths is nostalgia is
there is this intergenerational
component to it too where we're passing
down traditions and religions across
time and so there is this this this
aspect of nostalgia that is i think
encapsulating some of these old ideas
and especially around the importance of
like you said community
having a community having a family
focusing on those things a lot of
nostalgic memories are very much about
rights of passage important family in
religious traditions
and things like that
have you considered
what happens if
we're now kind of fighting the tide as
humans like if trying to create some
sort of cohesive meta-narrative that
ties everything together is essentially
that impossible like what if our brains
are overclocked for what we need and the
clash between
what we need and what we've dispensed
with as we've developed as a culture and
created science has just left us in this
sort of uncanny valley we can't go back
for most people i think it's more than
50 of america now describes themselves
as non-religious in one form or another
um
so we can't really go back to that sort
of a situation we're now praying at the
altar of science and rationality
but
it would appear i think i've seen you
quote about some global trends over time
with regards to meaning that there is a
little bit of a meaning crisis at the
moment
what if we're just stuck in this sort of
you bend
well i'm by nature an optimist so well
i'll balance you out quite nicely in
that case clay
okay so
that that's good and we need both sides
right um so i think
i think one thing that that is possible
and it relates again again it connects
to that idea of of rediscovering
ancient you know wisdom
is that yes we are in a we are an
unprecedented time especially with
technology
and the the way it connects us that
i don't just live in a little community
and you know i'm worried about you know
i'm worried about being liked and
successful and everything within my
little group like i can get online and
see what other people are doing all over
the world and now we just have we're
just bombarded with so much information
and even with the even with the supposed
rise of science and rationality and the
reason i say suppose it is
because people often talk about things
using scientific jargon
and you know using words that sound
rational but really they're just
expressing their their feelings and
their intuitions and their beliefs and
they're just decorating them those
scientific terminology
but i do think it because i do think
you're right it relates to the fact that
science has become like almost like a
religious
like movement um even though really it's
a methodology right it's a it's a set of
tools used to interrogate nature in
reality
um but people have turned it into this
um
this bigger
identity
but our brains haven't changed right we
still have the brains we had and for the
way things used to be long before
the the long before the the western
enlightenment long before modern
technology in our interconnected
world
but what i think is possible
is that
well you know we'll figure it out like
well
well you know we'll learn to you know
again maybe through science ironically
we'll learn that well you know what it's
not science and ration empiricism
isn't enough there's something
magical is not the right word because
there is a neurological explanation but
there's something that feels magical
about
the human experience that can't be just
summed up
by being acting like we're robots or
like we're um what's i don't know if
you're star trek fan um
you know there's like data the
he's the robot no
or the vulcans they're not wrong i mean
they're they're human-like but they
supposedly you know um
suppress their emotions and but we're
not like that right we the things that
give us meaning in life that's this is
another element of meaning is there's a
cognitive component of meaning the
things that give us meaning are
intuitive
then that is it feels meaningful so if
you go out in nature and you have an
experience that induces awe
that's an intuition that's a feeling
nothing you know if you are listening to
music
and you just let the music move through
if you're not a music critic who's
putting on your empirical brain to
you know to scrutinize
you know every element of it you're just
in the experience so meaning is very
experiential
and
yeah there is a you know there's a
crisis now and yes religion's in decline
um but i'm actually
not as convinced as
some people
that it won't come back not as it was
before
um
but as they'll that people won't figure
out that there is some aspect of the
human condition that is spiritual
and that that is something that
people that really makes life fulfilling
and i do think that we're we're
especially bad at this in in the west
i mean if you go to um
you know more um like
in east asia you know yeah there's a lot
of
um there's a lot of like non-religious
people um but there is more of a sense
of
um it's not weird to kind of be
dualistic about these things you can be
a scientist and
be spiritual like there seems to be
something about the individualistic west
that's more like well you have to be one
or the other right like you have to
um you're either committed to the
project of science and reason
or you're like some kind of weird hippie
spiritualist or religious fundamentalist
and
um and a lot of the world that's not
um
you know some of the
some of the you know most successful
scientists are are religious um
and so i do think that there i think
maybe we'll kind of figure out
like a more holistic path back to
you know there are there is something
about we we do need to nurture our
spiritual
side
and that's not
um hippie or weird or mystical or
you know that's just part of the human
condition and a lot of the cool things
that we do that are you know artistic
and inspiring um
very much tap into that side of our you
know those dimensions of our of our
brain
and
so you know i think i'd like to think
we'll we'll figure it out
i have a couple of buddies that call
themselves cultural christians
so that they don't necessarily ascribe
to sort of the the higher powers and
stuff like that but they really enjoy
the experiential side they like going to
church they're like sitting down they're
like being able to contribute to the
community and
doing
stuff for whatever it is autumn farm
giving and you know all of that and to
be honest the more and more that i've
thought about it especially this year
that really really sounds
quite
appealing
to me i'm asking i'm going to try and
get myself to go at some point and say
look man like i'd love to go along and
see what this is like
you said that
a part of human nature is inherently
spiritual what do you mean by that
yeah well when i say that i mean i i
mean you can you can think of that in a
totally materialistic paradigm i i think
so because a lot of times when people
say spiritual what they're what they're
they mean that there's something beyond
the biological something beyond the you
know the laws of physics
um and i'm not saying there isn't or is
i'm as an imp you know as a scientist
that's beyond my scope of inquiry right
like i can only study things that
you know are bound by the laws of nature
i'm not a
theologian or you know
right um but that doesn't mean that
there isn't experientially there isn't
something spiritual and i can be
agnostic about
you know that can be someone else's
problem whether there's something beyond
the material but within our house within
our brain right the the the cognitive
processes that drive human behavior
very materialistically
involve intuitive cognitions right we
have
um and you can study this in brain
studies right you can look at if you pee
there's different brain activity going
on when people are like focused on using
rational thinking to solve a math
problem
than when they're
just using their emotions and their
intuitions right these
in fact there's an argument that these
things are
um and these processes are antagonistic
to one another and what i mean by that
is that it's very difficult if not
impossible to simultaneously
do both
and so you can either
use your math like you know you can
either be solving you know logic
problems
um
or you can be feeling and experiencing
something and you can switch between the
two but you can't do that they're that
they're actually antagonistic to each
other you can't do them at the same time
and so in other words like you can put
on your intuition hat and say you know
what i'm not scrutinizing i'm not trying
to like tear this apart logically
i'm just experiencing it and then you
can put on your science hat and your you
know your rational hat and say like well
this happens to be the type of decision
that really needs to be informed by
evidence and reason and i think people
do this all the time
without knowing it and it's a classic
example of like the the the religious
scientist right so somebody can go to
church on sunday and say well in this
particular space
i'm not a scientist right like this is
an experiential space where i'm having a
spiritual
encounter that's that's about ritual
it's about community it's about
um
let you know like a leap of faith like
letting go a little bit it's
like a humility i don't know everything
there's something you know maybe there's
something beyond my
my reason you know my ability
um to to know you know everything
empirically and just to have that
experience
um and then you can monday morning go to
go to your laboratory and be like
there's no space for any of that kind of
stuff here like everything has to be
extremely methodical and empirical
and i think people do that all the time
not just with the religion but we do
that all we do that with the
relationships like people would probably
think you were weird if when you you
know if you're if you have a significant
other and that every day you were like
checking a checklist of here's the
things
you know here's the here's the pros and
cons of this relationship and you were
just making constant like empirical
evaluations and then you told your
spouse well here's the 10 things that
you suggest i should like you and
there's only eight that suggests it
shouldn't so i guess on the whole i love
you
like no you don't do that you see it's a
feeling right you love is a it's an
intuition it's a feeling and not that
it's not influenced by
empirical data gathering but when you
experience it like you'd be weird if
people if you took that methodical
approach
you probably would be single
pretty quickly so we do this all the
time right where we switch between
just throwing caution to the wind taking
a leap of faith like trusting our
intuitions and having you know having
experiences
versus
now's the time to really marshal all my
rational
capacities because i need to make an
informed uh um decision
does that make sense absolutely do you
think that at the moment we're seeing
people be too reliant on cerebral
horsepower and not enough on this sort
of embodied intuition
i mean i think it well i certainly think
people think they're
more reliant on it than they are and
this gets to you know issues that you
know of i think um
maybe group think and bias and i think
there's a lot of certainly in my world
you know i'm an academic
i think there's a lot of people and
and especially in the behavioral and
social sciences but the physical
sciences as well
who
act like because they have this role of
scientists
that they're just wholly empirical and
all the time
right that this is um as opposed to well
no in this one specific area of work
that you do
hopefully a good portion of the time
you're able to kind of overwhelm your
biases and your intuitions and you're
able to rely on the tools the objective
tools of science
to do that
um but you're not doing that all the
time
right you're and but i think people are
so i think people are over confident
that they're that they're using these
tools and and because we have this
culture that's acting like that's
everything like you're an idiot if all
your decisions aren't guided
by science um but i think a lot of that
is actually
just
it's just a narrative it's just a story
it's like a lot of things that people do
are not guided by
evidence they're guided by you know
experience they're guided by um habit
they're guided by
personality they're guided by intuitions
um
and it's not the case that people aren't
um are making choice you know aren't
making choices but this notion that
every single choice that they're making
is is based somehow on a rigorous
interrogation of evidence um
you i don't think you just make it very
far in life if you you'd be paralyzed by
by by indecision um and there are some
things that really it's just they don't
it doesn't matter like it just should be
like well this is what i wanna you know
this is what i wanna do and this is what
i'm into
and and that should be
and that should be fine um so yeah i
think maybe if we did a better job of
like i said hopefully we can get back to
this if we did a better job of carving
out a space where we said you know
there's a lot of life that is just
um us trying to figure it out and
explore ideas and have experiences and
you know you talked about this with the
with the the kind of totalitarian like
everyone needs to have the right to show
the right do the right virtue signaling
and show the right response it's like if
we just had more tolerance for
like people have you know people are
into different things and they have
different opinions and
they're not all like driven by like this
is the you know the science says this
right now and if you all don't fall in
line
then what you know what kind of idiots
are you but a lot of it's just more
messy than that so i know people are
figuring things out and they have
different with their legitimately
subjective opinions that you know that
there's not a single right answer
right it depends on what people care
about and what you know what risks
they're willing to take and
so i think we could you know i would
like to see us get to more of that and i
think a recognition of our you know our
spiritual or intuitive side would go a
long way in helping us get beyond this
like everything's just cold calculations
and if you're not making the right ones
then
you're an idiot because honestly i think
a lot of people
you know even the people that claim to
be doing that i think a lot of the times
they're just not they're just as biased
and intuitive as everyone else
i agree i think that
the most interesting thing one of the
most interesting things is
the implication that this has for
people's confidence in their own word
because if you think that the
standards the rigorous scientific
rationality standards where you need to
know the name of every cognitive bias
before you can set foot into the world
you're inevitably going to
question yourself so much more because
you understand there's this big chasm
between where you're operating at and
where you feel like you should be
operating like if i haven't imbibed the
entire rationalist movement and i like
be able to recite it word for word then
always i'm going to be making a lot of
mistakes in my life whereas if you look
at
you know some of the simplest people
that you know your friend that's just
really really happy being a young dad or
your friend is just really really happy
being a carpenter whatever he's like you
know i've got friends that are djs and
they don't think really too much about
higher meaning they really love the job
that they do they love playing music
they love making people happy and that's
it and they live this sort of party boy
lifestyle and they're having a great
time
and then reinventing this and and the
yeah the comeuppance of the scientific
movement has been that
when people on an individual level have
taken this in they've thought right well
i need to be able to justify to myself
rationally scientifically all of the
different actions that i'm going to take
you go well how do you think we got here
for like thousands and thousands of
years people weren't able to do this and
i understand that if there is a best way
if there's an optimal strategy for
achieving anything then trying to get
closer to that
should result in you operating more
efficiently
but
not if
the chasing of that efficiency causes
you to suffer so much during the chase
that it completely negates any of the
gains that you're going to get in any
case and this is this is the virtuous
mean right it's i want to know the
things that i want to know but i need to
also be aware of the fact that i'm
fallible and i'm this weird
phenomenological creature that's just
going to feel things and just kind of
have faith in my in my embodied self and
this is
yeah this is something that i think when
you dispense with religion
there's no there's nothing for people to
fall back on they can't just have faith
in the fact that they're doing things
right and god will step in if i'm doing
it wrong there isn't any higher power
the the cold harsh grey truth of
rationality is that
existential agency is purely mine to
find to create it's my inertia to
overcome it's my momentum to maintain
and if i don't do it
then oh my god maybe my life's not worth
anything and that's where we end up
yeah that's an interesting point i mean
and and to be clear that
you know obviously
science
and rationality
you know have dramatically
improved our lives but that but and we
all can you know we all can contribute
to that like we but but that brings up
the point of it's not science is not an
individual accomplishment right science
is a set of tools
that people can add to their toolkit of
how to you know of how to do things but
it's just part of the it's just part of
the
part of the story and part of the
solution so i think you're right like
you have to have
or it helps to have these to embrace the
fact that there are other aspects of the
human condition
that aren't purely empirical and that
aren't purely scientific and oftentimes
those are the things that make life
worth living
and
you know it doesn't mean it's not like a
black and white it doesn't mean like we
should reject science i mean i think
we're very you and i wouldn't be having
this conversation
over the internet you know thousands of
miles apart if it wasn't for advances in
science and technology
and so i think you can simultaneously
appreciate that and champion that
and also recognize that that's just part
of the part of the picture that there's
a fuller picture and one that involves
um
you know the head versus heart metaphor
is a is a good example
it's like we need both right the head
you know this is a metaphor obviously
because all of our feelings and stuff
come out of our brain too but people
naturally understand this metaphor they
they say follow your heart or you you
know use your head follow your heart
kind of
this kind of metaphor so we you know
it's worth recognizing that both are
important the the heart makes life worth
worth living you know it makes science
worth pursuing right it makes the heart
is what makes you say you know what i
want to cure diseases i want to make the
world more comfortable for people
um but
if it's just focused on you know if
you're just entirely focused on science
and not the value that it that that
provides to making actual people's lives
better um then i do think you you you
lose something and again i just think a
lot of people
they have this identity like it's an
identity like i'm a science
person
and i i i think it would be helpful if
we got away from that because like no
you know like it's not it's not a
defining characteristic like it's a job
and science is a set of tools
it's a methodology
that we use to interrogate nature in
reality it's not
it's not like a
personal
identity
um that you know that that just makes
every decision you you've ever made
rational it's just part of what it's
just part of what it's part of the
toolkit of what we do
to to advance human progress and to you
know to make life better
clay rutledge ladies and gentlemen
thanks for coming on man where should
people go if they want to check out more
of your stuff
well i have a website that's just
clayrelage.com
um they can check there i am on twitter
i think it's just at clay rutledge
yeah those are probably the best the
best places
thanks very much for today
thank you it's great to have this
conversation with you thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few months and don't forget to
subscribe makes me very happy indeed
peace